édouard the first known as Longshanks
for his uncharacteristic height was a
man among men and a king among kings as
a child he was so sickly that few
thought he would survive to even take
the crown but take it he dips
immediately displaying a strength and
determination that had been sorely
lacking he quickly established his
authority with ruthless suppression of
rebellion earning him the nickname the
hammer of the Scots and the adoration of
all of England in this week's biographic
Sui get up close and personal with the
man who was Edward Longshanks the king
of England
Edward the first future King of England
was born at Westminster Palace in London
on June the 17th
12:39 he was the first born son of King
Henry the third and eleanor of provence
henry was a great admirer of previous
King Edward the Confessor and named his
son in his honor Edward was not a well
child in fact he was so weak that the
general consensus was that he wouldn't
survive into adulthood but survived he
did growing into an unusually tall and
rather robust teenager he would
eventually grow to a height of six foot
two which allowed him to tower over most
of his contemporaries it was his unusual
height which would lead soldiers to
refer to him as Longshanks during his
formative years edward was groomed to
take the mantle of king he was educated
by the best scholars and members of the
clergy hero became his physical
weaknesses to become an able wielder of
the sword and club as well as a keen
student of the arts and languages at the
age of 15 edward entered into an
arranged marriage with a 13 year old
eleanor daughter of ferdinand the third
of castile the union was precipitated by
the fear of a Castilian invasion of the
province of Gascony as part of their
marriage contract Edward received land
grants worth fifteen thousand marks
annually in taxation this land covered
much of Ireland and Wales
however the entitlement that the teenage
Prince had was only in name as the lands
were still controlled by his father and
the income generated went not to him but
rather to the raw left-hand
Monford the 6th Earl of Leicester the
Earl of Leicester was married to the
King's sister Edward did benefit from
the marriage Alliance on a more personal
level unlike the vast majority of such
arranged unions he and Alan and
genuinely cared for each other and that
fondness grew into a love that lasted
their entire lives
[Music]
King Henry was an extremely pious man
whose main focus as King was on building
up the authority and symbolism of the
church he devoted himself to rebuilding
Westminster Abbey putting his energies
into this project at the expense of more
pressing concerns of state a series of
ill-advised military forays each of
which ended in failure added fuel to the
fire of discontent with his reign among
the nobility attempts were made to usurp
the Kings authority and wrestle power
away from him the two most powerful
noble factions at that time with a
Salette and cologne families who were
opposed to each other
Henry pushed a policy of neutrality
between the camps in 12:55 however the
16 year old Edward began siding with the
Soler family this marked his first act
of independence from his father in the
following year and we began associating
with what was called the loose in your
faction made up of the half-brothers of
his father who were a French origin this
group was largely despised by the
nobility and had a reputation for being
rather uncouth and violent concerns were
expressed in the royal court over the
increasing wildness of Edwards conduct
when he was with the Lu seniors three
years later a body of nobles drew up a
document known as the provisions of
Oxford which spelled out a series of
reforms designed to give the Barons much
more say in the running of the Kings
government the Baron's were especially
opposed to the influence of the loosen
Yass relations between Henry and his
brother-in-law Simon de Montfort had
been strained from the very start Simon
had not sought the Kings permission for
marriage to his sister Simon then
proceeded to amass large debts naming
the King as guarantor again without his
permission
Simon was at the forefront of the Barons
efforts to bring reform and the pressure
imposed eventually led to the Kings
signing the provisions he was now
obligated to seek the counsel of his
barons on matters relating to the
governing of the kingdom as the pressure
began to mount on his father Edward
remains
loyal to his friends the loosin yawns
and took a stance in opposition to the
provisions of Oxford but as the reform
movement grew in intensity his position
it shifted on October 12 59 he announced
that he was supportive of the goals of
the Barons and aligned himself with his
father's rival Simon de Montfort in
November 12 59 King Henry embarked on a
voyage to France
in his absence Edwards opposition to his
father a group he appointed several of
the rebellious barons to important
positions within the raw court when news
of this reached his father in Normandy
he was convinced that Edward was about
to stage an overthrow he quickly
returned to London to reimpose his
position at first the outraged Henry
refused to even see Edward but finally
the sort of peace was brokered between
them by the Archbishop of Canterbury it
was decided that Edward was to go abroad
which he did at the age of 21 in
November 1260 he ended up in France
where he fell in love with his old pals
the Lucien Yuans
meanwhile in 1261 King Henry with the
backing of the Pope in Rome overthrew
the provisions of Oxford
they said the Barons to set up their own
independent Parliament's with civil war
looming this noble Parliament it was
dissolved and the noble rebellious
barons they fled De Montfort himself I
left the country but he returned two
years later when the heat had died down
the one foot managed to raise a sizable
army and marched on London the King
vacillated and seemed it ready to give
up his throne it was at this point that
Edwards stepped up and began to take
control of the situation any hesitancy
he had previously shown in supporting
his father's rule had vanished and he
was now staunchly determined to restore
the Kings dominance he took control of
the king's army and led them in defense
of the realm the rebels were ousted from
Windsor Castle a compromise of sorts was
reached thanks to the intervention of
King bluey the 9th of France who
negotiated the agreements known as the
meze of Amir the vase between the king
and the Barons was short-lived in 1264
hostilities broke out once more with the
onset of what history recalls as the
second barons war once again the Barons
were led by Simon de Montfort while the
forces loyal to the king were buds of
the control of the now 24 year old
Prince Edward in the wake of a series of
smaller victories Edward's army met up
with the forces of De Montfort at the
Battle of Loos on may the 14th 1264
things went well for the royalist forces
as they managed to force the London
contingent of the opposition into
retreat but then Edward made the mistake
of breaking off with a portion of his
army to chase down the Londoners when he
returned to the main scene of the battle
his forces had been defeated
Edward was taken as a prisoner and held
until the following May when he managed
to escape over the next few months the
rawest forces steadily wore down the
resistance army the most telling victory
was at the Battle of Evesham on August
the 4th 1265 the Baron's army was
ravaged with many of its leaders being
put to the sort Simon de Montfort was
himself killed when a Lance was run
through his body Edward then allowed his
soldiers do mutilate the body including
cutting off the testicles and hanging
them over de Montfort snows such actions
were strictly against the protocol of
war which stipulated that Nobles were to
be treated humanely
however dead would consider de Montfort
to be a traitor and therefore beyond the
rules
conduct the last of the rebels made a
stand at Kenilworth Castle finally
surrendering in accordance with the
terms of the dictum of Kenilworth
edwards decisive actions and leadership
skills during the barons rebellion
showed him to be a man of action who
possessed the courage ability and
personality to be a great king yes with
the rebellion crushed and his father's
rulership a shirt he put his focus on an
upcoming crusade King Louie the 9th of
France was planning a crusade to North
Africa in order to defeat the Muslims in
Edward left England with a force of
around 1200 men along with him was his
wife Eleanor after crossing the channel
and then the Mediterranean they arrived
at North Sarika you need to discover the
French King was dead the result of a
fatal bout of dysentery Edward was now
the leader of the allied force and he
chose to withdraw the fleet to Sicily
however on routes a severe storm
decimated the fleet and the French
contingent decided to return home rather
than following the French example Edward
decided to forge ahead he landed at
Accra on May the 9th 1271 the Christian
Empire in the Holy Land was under
serious threat from the Muslim States
with Jerusalem already having fallen in
1244 the Egyptian Mamluks were now
threatening to take Accra which served
as the Christian capital with a
relatively small force of men there was
little Edward could do to stem the tide
of Muslim aggression the Mamluk warrior
King Babar's had tens of thousands of
men under his command before departing
for home however it would played a part
in the negotiation the truce with
Baybars
once the treaty was signed he stayed for
a period of time to ensure that its
conditions would be carried out one
night in September of 12 72 an assassin
entered the bedchamber of Edward and
Elinor in order to attempt to thrust a
poisonous dagger into the princes on
Edward was able to fend off the attack
and kill the assassin legend has it that
Alan s sucked the poison from her
husband's arm thus saving his life
[Music]
in the wake of the foiled assassination
plot the royal couple they left the Holy
Land upon sailing to sicily edward was
given the news that his father the king
had died
edward had been weakened by the poison
attack and so now as king of England's
he and Eleanor his queen took a
leisurely trip home the situation back
in England it was pretty stable so he
didn't really see a need to rush back
Edward made his way home through dirtily
and then on to France crossing the
channel in early August of 1274 Edward
was officially crowned King Edward the
first on August the 19th 1274 at
Westminster Abbey when the crown was
placed upon his head a chronicler
reported that Edward immediately took it
off again and stated that he would only
wear it again when all of the territory
that was lost during the kingship of his
father was returned the new king was 35
years old he was tall muscular and
militarily adept he was the man of
action that his father had simply not
been you see he enjoyed the roughest and
most dangerous forms of hunting such as
going after boars and wolves as a
younger man he was prone to flying off
the handle but age had restrained his
temper by the time he ascended to the
throne he had built a reputation as a
loyal friends and a devoted ruler
however he was also known as a hard man
who could be harsh even cruel in the
furtherance of his own will Edwards
reign it was not going to be a
continuation of his father's week and
lenient rule he immediately set about
re-establishing the dominance of the
crown his other power was son questions
but he saw that in order to retain power
he had to institute policies that were
popular with the people determined to
prevent a repeat of the civil war that
had scarred his father's reign he made
lasting provision for the lower classes
to be represented in Parliament this
established the basis of the House of
Commons which today is the predominant
house in the English political system
[Music]
during first years of his reign Edward
focused primarily on streamlining and
reforming the administration of his
government he then turned his attention
to the situation that was occurring in
Wales the Prince of Wales luanne in-app
CRIF a.m. had been handed the title by
King Henry the third in return for
agreeing to pay homage to the English
crown
Llewelyn however had been an ally of
Henry and Edward's enemies Simon de
Montfort and set about conquering of the
Welsh kingdoms and was now threatening
to move against England itself edward
acted preemptively
leading a force of 10,000 across the
Welsh border however Llewellyn's
unpopularity at home prevented him from
raising a sizable army to counter the
English invasion in fact as his army
moved up the Welsh countryside Edwards
forces were strengthened by the addition
of local Welsh armies who were opposed
to Llywelyn among those who joined
Edward was Llewellyn's own brother
defeat the upstart was soon deposed and
Edward claims large swaths of Welsh
territory as his own he rewarded a fit
by giving him a small parcel of lands
now was not pleasing to him and he felt
that he deserved much more for his
service to the crown in 1282 defit led a
revolt against the king that was soon
joined by his seething brother Llewellyn
an angry Edward responded by invading
Wales a second time this time however he
was determined to go all out with a
three-pronged attack from the south east
and the north the English invasion was
unstoppable resulting in these stomping
out of the rebellion and the death in
battle of Llewellyn for his party's
effort was captured and executed edward
consolidated his victory in Wales by
constructing a series of castles
throughout the lands the most impressive
was at Caernarfon it was here that
Edwards son and future heir Edward ii
was born in 1284 the now vacant title of
Prince of Wales was bestowed upon the
child and since that time the heir to
the British throne has been given that
title in a ceremony that is held at
conovan Castle when it came to foreign
relations Edward did his best to
maintain peaceful relations with his
European counterparts despite the fact
that Philip the third of France was his
cousin relations between the two powers
were under constant tension when Philip
died in 1285 Edward crossed the channel
in order to pay homage to the new French
King Philip the fourth he did not return
to England until 1289 spending much time
in the Duchy of Gascony which was one of
his possessions in 1287 Edward took the
cross for the second time intending to
stage another far more successful
crusade to retake the holy lands
from the Muslims he knew that success in
this enterprise depended on the
stitching together of a truly
international European alliance towards
that end he expended much effort trying
to preserve peace among the powers
Edwards long absence from London had
thrown the government into confusion and
chaos he returned to discover the
corruption was rife and was forced in
disgust to expel many of his judges and
ministers all of them the 28th 1290
felon had died after suffering a
protracted illness that may have been
malaria she was just 48 years of age
having spent 35 of them at Edwards side
the king was distraught at the loss of
his wife he became a hardened man in the
wake of her loss more bitter and
brooding in nature
Edwards campaign against the well should
imposed huge financial burdens upon its
nation taxes were the main way to meet
those expenses and a prime source of
that taxation were the Jews of England
Edward tax the Jews far more heavily
than any other group in 1279 he ordered
the arrest of all the heads of Jewish
households throughout the country about
300 of them were put to death the
following year all Jews were ordered to
attend special sermons preached by
Dominican friars in order to convert
them to Christianity then in 1290 Edward
issued the Edict of expulsion by which
all Jews were kicked out of England it
wasn't until 16 56 that the Jewish ban
in England was finally lifted
[Music]
from 1290 onward Edwards attention was
focused on troubles in Scotland
following the death of Alexander the
third in 1286 Scotland's was governed in
the name of his granddaughter Margaret
King Edward had made the suggestion that
his eldest surviving son Edward of
Karneval Margaret should be united in
marriage bringing about the union of
England and Scotland before this could
happen though Margaret died the Scottish
throne was now in dispute with a number
of claimants the English King was asked
to play the role of arbitrator and
Edward agreed but on the condition that
the claimants accept him as their
overlord in 1292 he awarded the throne
to John Balliol who was crowned as the
new king it didn't take long however for
the Scottish people to resent the
jurisdictional control that Edward held
over their country
John was deprived of all his power and
the Scots formed an alliance with France
by this time England's relations with
the French had deteriorated things had
come to a head when Philip the fourth
refused to restore the Duchy of Gascony
to Edward in 1293 Edward declared war on
France at the very time that the Scots
had united with Scotland to make a bad
situation worse the Welsh chose this
time to rise in rebellion King John of
Scotland gathered his forces in March of
1296 Edward mustered his forces and
again marched into battle many Scottish
Nobles including Robert the Bruce sided
with Edward whose first target city was
the City of Berwick it turns into a
brutal massacre of the Scots with many
people being killed next target was the
castle at Dunbar despite having the
higher grounds the Scottish defenders
were routed on April the 27th 1296 the
Scottish army was virtually wiped out
allowing Edward to quickly take a
succession of castles all that remained
was for King John to surrender on July
the 2nd John sent a pleading letter to
Edward begging forgiveness and mercy
Edward accepted but only after
subjugating John to a series of
humiliations including having the
Scottish coat of arms torn from his sir
coat he was then thrown into the Tower
of London but Edward wasn't finished
with Scotland's he was determined to
stamp out any vestiges of Scottish
independence and to absorb its people
into the English Kingdom he demanded
oaths of fealty from all Scottish Nobles
magnates
and either refused to do so were hunted
down as outlaws
[Music]
after conquering the Scots Edward
returned south he now had to focus on
issues with the French
however the masses in Scotland were not
ready to subject themselves to the heel
of Edward Longshanks resistance grew
under three divergent leaders in the
southwest Robert the Bruce emerged as
the head of a gathering of nobles and
church leaders in the Northeast the
struggle was spearheaded by Andrew
Murray and in the center of the country
forces were being gathered by an obscure
member of a noble family named William
Wallace in 1297 Wallace murdered the
English sheriff of lanark William de
historic this act United the disjointed
pockets of resistance into a full-blown
rebellion two months later with the
situation reaching a crisis point Edward
was forced to send his left tenants in
to deal with the situation meanwhile he
had his own battle to fight in Flanders
in France even though we didn't want his
conquest of Scotland to run Ravel he
also knew that abandoning planned French
invasion would only strengthen the
rebels hand as things turned out the
British underestimated the strength of
the Scottish resistance what appeared to
be a Scottish attempted and negotiated
surrender was in fact a ruse to allow
Wallace more time to gather his army
with his army strength and Wallace
managed to push the English from five
per share and Dundee the climactic
battle occurred at Stirling Bridge the
English outnumbered the Scots six to one
but when the leader of the first
vanguard hugh decreasing him was
reputedly struck down by wallace himself
thousands following turn and fled while
this went on to exploit the terrain and
generally outmaneuver the british to win
a resounding victory
Wallace quickly led his ever-growing
forces to overthrow the remaining
English outposts in Scotland he then
crossed the border and invaded English
territory after taking Northumberland's
he reached as far south as Cockermouth
with this it was time for Edward to take
control of the situation personally in
1298 the king's army gathered Roxburgh
with the king joining them in early July
he marched north with 17,000 men by now
Wallace had returned to Scotland
Edward was determined to hunt him down
though Wallace however he was not keen
to engage the King and drew the monarch
further north the Scots had stripped the
lands leaving the English with no food
and a stretched-out supply line with his
army disintegrating Edward had a stroke
of luck when intelligence was received
that Wallace and his men were stationed
far Kirke about 20 miles away the King
immediately set his army and the
erection of our the Scots they were
surprised but they were in a strongly
entrenched position in the end though
the strength of the English infantry and
cavalry assaults was too much for the
Scottish army and they were torn to
pieces while it's managed to escape and
let pockets of resistance for the next
seven years but the English they were
able to re-establish dominance over
Scotland in 1305 William Wallace was
finally captured by the English it was
taken to London where it was hung drawn
and quartered
[Music]
however this wasn't the end of the
Scottish problem for Edward in 1306
Robert the Bruce assassinated rival for
the throne which had been vacant for 10
years he then had himself crowned King
of Scotland he was quickly defeated in
battle with the English after which he
went into hiding only to return in 1307
to conduct hit-and-run raids on English
fortresses Edwards now in failing health
was still determined to bring up this
latest Scottish rebel to heal he again
gathered his army and headed north on
the journey to Scotland however the King
contracted dysentery on the morning of
July the 7th 1307 he died just a few
miles short of the Scottish border it is
said that he left instructions with his
son for the flesh to be boiled from his
body and his bones to be preserved then
every time the Scots should rebel
against him his son would carry with him
the bones of his father instead his body
was taken back to London where it was
placed in a plain tomb in Westminster
Abbey 700 years later that tomb is still
on display reminding visitors of the
strength and authority of one of
England's most impressive monix so I
really hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every day
of the week also got another channel
it's called today I found out we do
actually daily videos on that channel
exploring all manner of interesting
things please find our link to that on
the screen now as well as below this
video and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]